good morning John I kind of feel like
we've been really fancy on vlogbrothers
lately got music video big epic collab
video travel vlogs tax plans Brazil
video you did a review of monopoly let's
simplify for a while I'm just gonna tell
a story a couple of years ago I was in a
bid the Bay Area I landed and I was
going to a hotel that was a while away
so I got in a taxi it took me to the
hotel taxi driver he was super nice he
asked me where I was from we talked
about Montana he asked me why I was
there we talked about while I was there
which is that I was doing a thing for
the launch of Randall Monroe's book what
if which is a fantastic book I even read
to him a little bit from the book
because I just think that what if is
such a great thing to share with people
like a paragraph in the taxi driver he's
like oh no and so I am also like what
what happened he tells me that the cable
that connects the meter to the
transmission has fallen out deaning it
hadn't recorded the first part of our
journey and if he plugged it in now then
he'd only get paid for half but he said
he'd be fine because he does this trip a
lot he knows how much it costs he'll
just charge me that to get to the hotel
and he tells me 120 bucks and I say okay
I'm gonna go to bed I get up in the
morning I do the event it's great and
then I get another taxi from that same
hotel to the airport and it's 65 bucks
and then they realized like it didn't
even occur to me but yeah and of course
immediately I'm like that guy was only
nice to me because he wanted to know
where I was from and he was trying to
make it seem like there's no way this
could be the kind of guy that would take
advantage of me he's so nice I think
about all the ways in which I could have
protected myself from that like so many
common sense little things that I could
have done to prevent myself from getting
taken advantage of in that way mostly
just being ashamed that I was such like
a country bumpkin rube that I was this
guy's mark I was the Patsy and it made
me feel like an idiot for trusting
someone and not being more skeptical
this one little example of the world
like not always being totally on my side
and I start rethinking my entire like
policy of being intentionally over
trusting which is a thing that I
actually think about I want to be that
so this guy definitely stole like 50 60
bucks for me but that by far was not the
greatest like negative impact that this
experience had on me suddenly I'm
thinking like how do I avoid getting
taken advantage of again all the space
in my brain that my new like theft
protection algorithms are gonna take up
and just generally bill
the wall between me in the world that's
gonna decrease my enjoyment of the world
and this from me
a guy who's pretty much got the whole
world on his side I'm a straight white
dude with money just one little betrayal
and I'm rethinking the way I think about
all other humans come on maybe every act
of trust is a gamble that we choose to
me but I think the feeling of being
taken advantage of is way less pleasant
than the feeling of having your trust be
justified and having the good desired
outcome happen on the scale of
violations of trust of course a
taxi-driver stealing your money and you
not being smart enough to like realize
it's happening is really far down the
scale I don't want to say that this is
like a huge terrible thing that happened
to me I'm just surprised at the impact
it had on me and I feel like if I let
that change the way I think about the
world that's not bad for the scammer or
the thief that's bad for me but if that
guy is rationalizing his theft or if
anybody is rationalizing them taking
advantage of other people by saying like
yeah that person can afford to have that
stuff taken from them whatever that is
maybe maybe that's the case maybe I can
afford to have 60 bucks stolen from me
but I don't think that our society can
afford to be constantly looking over its
shoulder we have to be able to trust
each other or society falls apart that
to me is the true untold unrecognized
cost of being the kind of person who
takes advantage of other people's trust
that thing not the theft is what ends up
making the world a significantly worse
place and it makes me really angry John
I'll see you on Tuesday hello there
endscreen if you're interested in being
part of a street team for my upcoming
tour dates in the description there is a
link in the description to a form that
you can fill out it would be great if
you wanted to help us out